well it's been a long time since I sat
down and made a long video and talked to
you guys at length a lot of things going
on in my life as you might be able to
tell I recently moved so this is a new
setup this will be the setup I've also
been a little sick lately so my voice
might not be at 100% but come on I had
to come back I had to get into the
second part of my my series here right
this is my favorite albums of the 2010s
previous video went from number 30 to 21
this video we're starting at 20 we're
going to 11 we're doing another 10
albums I'm not interested in wasting any
time so let's just get right into it so
coming in at number 20 this is an album
I mentioned in the previous video but
it's uh celebration Rock from Japan
[Music]
Droids I was going to say I don't think
there's anything special about this
vinyl but I just pulled it out and
realized it is pressed on white wax
which is pretty cool I can't remember
exactly when or how I found Japan Droids
but I would guess that it was because a
pitchfork I know that they were well
received for this album and probably
some others but I thought the name Japan
Droids was pretty cool but even cooler
was the name of this album celebration
Rock I thought okay if you're going to
call your album that it better be just
that and sure enough it's kind of what
it is a lot of great triumphant anthems
on here I know when I mentioned them
before it was while I was discussing go
farther in lightness from gang of Youth
there's definitely some similarities
between the bands and that they're doing
the big emotional Rock thing I'm not
aware of too many bands that are working
in that space But I really appreciate
what these guys are doing in addition to
being very celebratory there's also a
lot of wistfulness and reminiscence and
the album also opens and closes with the
sound of fireworks so I mean you better
have something good in between almost
every song in this album I love there's
some amazing stretches of just again
it's really triumphant emotional Rock
it's feel-good rock of course not all
the songs are necessarily celebratory
when you get into the lyrics some of the
tracks are filled with um regret or just
kind of looking back on youth which
isn't dark necessarily but it's not too
celebratory nevertheless there's enough
celebration rock on here that I don't
think the name is a misnomer my favorite
track on here honestly one of my
favorite songs period it really is that
good is the house that heaven built
really amazing song another great one is
younger us that obviously is one that's
looking to the past but just beautiful
stuff man these guys really have a knack
for tugging at the heartstrings with
very powerful Rock Anthems for anyone
who hasn't heard this album it's pretty
short you should be able to sit through
it fairly easily of course you might
have to get up and run around the room
in celebration too but you know
experience that on your own when we on
the moving on to number 19 we have M Dem
Marco this old
[Music]
dog believe it or not this one is also
pressed on white wax two in a row
wouldn't have thought so this album it
wasn't my first exposure to MC DeMarco
obviously I had heard some of the hits
before I heard some of his previous
albums but when this one came out in
2017 and I started listening to it it
just it stuck with me in a way that not
much of his music has the whole album
top to bottom is produced by m DeMarco
he did the entire thing himself which I
always find impressive I love when
artists are capable of making the entire
thing they're making and I think there's
a there's a Simplicity to the music on
this one the instrumentals are kind of
loose and playful and the subject matter
is not songs like sister and watching
him Fade Away have an undeniable
Darkness or a weight to them and of
course the opener my old man that one's
very introspective Max's talking about
seeing more of his dad and himself and I
know he's got a strained relationship
with his father so it it's cool to see
sort of introspec
biographical music about MC dearco I
feel like a lot of his work is a bit
more cryptic or just goofy but I think a
lot of the content on this one is more
centered even though production-wise it
feels fun and almost like a Summer album
maybe that Jos is why I love this one so
much cuz I can just put it on and vibe
to it but if I actually sit down
listening to the lyrics there's a lot of
depth there this definitely holds the
title for my favorite Mac DeMarco album
uh one Wayne G is great that super long
one but this one's going to be number
one for the foreseeable future almost
every track on here is is fantastic if
you ask me if I had to pick some
favorites though for you I would say
still beating which is a great love song
and another great one is a wolf who
wears sheep's clothes that one's kind of
fun the instrumental is just fantastic
it's such a great production on that
track really just a joy to listen to and
that's kind of how I would describe the
album even if the album isn't joyful
it's a lot of fun highly replayable
highly comforting exactly my kind of
[Music]
thing number 18 on the list is in
hindsight an album that I should
probably put higher cuz I really love it
that much this is J Paul's 0413 bait
ones there's nothing special visually to
point out about this record but it means
a lot to me because this was the last of
these 30 to enter my collection very
limited drop I was clamoring to get
through the website to buy it it's on J
Paul's crazy cryptic website and I did
not get the initial drop but my fiance
surprised me with this one as a gift
which is just amazing I'm so grateful
and so happy to finally have this one
cuz it's been a long time coming I mean
for years I would have accepted even a
bootleg of this album I just wanted to
have it in my collection cuz it's so
great so if you don't know anything
about J Paul and know it's not Jake Paul
he's a really cool sort of futuristic
R&B artist R&B doesn't even feel like
the best Des scriptor because his music
kind of transcends genre but anyway he
had a couple great singles back in the
beginning of the decade that was 2011
2012 with tracks like Jasmine and btstu
both of which are fantastic and they're
on this project so in 2013 album leaked
I'm not entirely sure how somebody got a
hold of his laptop I'm not sure but the
album was put up for sale I think on his
band camp people were buying it and the
labels and critics everybody just kind
of took it as he just surprised dropped
his album meanwhile he was not ready to
drop it then he had to scramble to get
it taken down it sounds like the event
was very traumatic for him because he
sort of stopped making music and just
kind of receded Into Obscurity after
that he was gone for a long time and I
believe it was 2019 that he finally came
came back and officially released the
album it's not very different from the
leak that initially came out though some
of the samples had to get cleared I
think he recognizes that despite the
fact that it was a leak people really
grew attached to his work so this one's
important for the decade for obvious
reasons it kind of came out in 2013 and
it became a part of me for years and
years before officially re-releasing or
officially releasing at the end of the
decade so it was kind of odd you know
that this album came out and I was
already a huge fan of never had that
experience before and honestly wouldn't
want to have it again cuz it just seems
kind of stressful it seems like a
logistical nightmare for a guy like J
Paul but yeah this album is really
really something it feels like it came
from the future it really does even now
there's just so much to this that is
unlike anything else that's out there he
Blends a lot of non-conventional
instruments and samples with sort of R&B
type music I'm not sure how much of the
production he handles himself but I
would imagine he's involved in it cons
considerably because who else is making
this kind of music he does have a
brother that He makes music with to who
goes by AK Paul I don't think he
contributes at all this album I just
thought I'd point that out because he's
got some stuff that is similar and also
really cool again this is a short album
I'm realizing a lot of my picks here are
relatively brief and maybe that's part
of what makes a good album everybody out
there who makes the long ones take notes
the easy answers here for favorite songs
would be Jasmine and btsu those are
obviously the singles that preceded the
album I can't not recommend Jasmine
because that's one of my favorite songs
period but if you're looking for
something a little deeper than btsu
another great track is straight out of
Mumbai that's the sort of like Club
Banger pop track that I I just I don't
know anything else that sounds like that
it's fantastic if you haven't listened
to this album please go do so it's going
to change your perspective on music I
can say that pretty comfortably for
anybody who hasn't heard it it's just
that
different number 17 on this list goes to
a band that's been one of my favorites
since I was pretty young it's uh angels
and airwav specifically Ty Al their
album
love now this vinyl is of course a
combination of Love Parts one and two
there was a follow-up album so the
initial love album became part one and
they did they did both release in the
decade so technically I could include
both but I think it's more important
here for me to just highlight my
favorite which is part one if you're not
familiar with Angels and Airwaves this
is a band that Tom dong started after he
left Blink 182 he joined up with a
couple buddies and decided to start
making music about space and love and I
think that's pretty rad of course I was
a big fan of blake2 as a kid and when
this stuff happened I was in Middle
School so it was the perfect time for me
to get into Emo music in middle school
and you know Tom dong he's a goofball
it's not like he's making the heaviest
music ever with this but he's aspiring
to something more than what blink182 was
and I think that that in itself is
admirable I feel like critics and a lot
of people don't really respect his work
here and that's you know it's okay I
just love it you know it means a lot to
me this is one of those picks that I
have have to keep in here because I have
to respect who I was at that time and I
still I still stand by the fact that
their music is really enjoyable they've
got some great albums including this one
this one came out I was in high school
it was like on Valentine's Day I think
and I believe it dropped for free which
again this is all just very cool
solidified in this point in time in my
mind and there's just so much to it that
I really really enjoy it it's almost
like they're shooting for kind of a
Prague punk I don't know if that's
appropriate at all I might get [__] and
feathered for saying something like that
look I'm just not good with genre okay
that's not my specialty I don't even
have a specialty just leave me alone
please but this album actually was also
intended to be a soundtrack for a film
of the same name that they put out which
again this is like cool aspirational
stuff for a guy that came from a band
that made songs about well I don't need
to get into that
I love Blink 182 but obviously Tom was
going for something more mature and it's
interesting too that he went the space
route because as you might know he's now
somebody who's very vocal about aliens
and has been kind of working with the
government or with ex-government people
to get alien stuff released which is
crazy what a trajectory for that
guy I've always loved his voice and I
think he does a great job contributing
to the music they make here I think it's
actually put Angels and Airwaves over
blink182 at least their first few albums
they just mean more to me if you've
never heard Angels and Airwaves I'd
probably recommend starting even earlier
with their debut we don't need to
whisper but if you want just listen to a
couple tracks on here my favorites are
probably the flight of Apollo and
letters to God part two look I've always
been a fan of space and I just thought
it was so cool that one of my favorite
singers from one of my favorite bands
decided to stop making pop punk music
and to start making emo space rock music
it's definitely worth checking out if
you haven't I think it's a fantastic
album would I put it as high on the list
if I were to make this list today
probably not but again out of respect
for who I was when I made this list and
who I was at that point in the decade I
got to include this where it is
[Music]
the number 16 we've got the self-titled
from bony
ver nothing special to show with this
vyl but it did come with a DVD of the
music videos I should have it up there
somewhere and I can still remember I
bought this one for I think $12 on eBay
and the fact that it came with that DVD
too I was like man what a great deal so
hopefully everybody watching this video
is familiar with bony be if not well
where do I start it really feels weird
trying to explain who bony be is cuz I
don't f
understand he's a very important figure
in this sort of alternative singer
songwriter space it's actually a band
it's not just one guy the one guy that
I'm really talking about is Justin
Vernon he's kind of the spear hood of it
he's the singer I think he plays most of
the instruments but bony bear
technically is a band he had a big
breakthrough album that he made at the
beginning of the previous decade that's
for Emma Forever Ago notoriously made in
a cabin when he was healing from an
illness and a breakup that's a fantastic
album too but I really think he stepped
up his game with the self-title the
instrumentals are incredibly light and
Airy sort of like the MC dearco but a
bit more natural maybe I'm saying that
because of the DVD with the music videos
that are all kind of nature scenes to go
with the music but it very much has that
Vibe bony be's got a great voice he's a
great songwriter even though I don't
always understand what he's singing
about I don't think you need to to enjoy
the music if you haven't heard it
there's a track on here called Hol scene
start there that's one of the great
songs you might find that you have
already heard it but it's just such a
beautiful comforting track really hard
to even pick favorites on this album
because again like so many of these
others on my list it's pretty short I
tend to listen to the whole thing in
full but I guess to get a taste of
something a little different you could
go with the closer Beth rest that one
there's more of like a piano or organ on
the track and it just has a different
feeling than a lot of the albums but it
feels like a great conclusive track
again as I feel like I'm saying with all
of these albums as I said with probably
all of them on the previous video you
should probably just listen to the whole
thing if you haven't it's not going to
take a whole lot of your time and it's
it's not like it's going to upset you
cuz the music is that gentle but yeah if
if you're looking for peace if you're
looking for tranquility this is what I
would
recommend number 15 on the list has got
to go to Travis Scott with
Rodeo Travis Scott released an album
this year Utopia you're probably aware
that was his first in about 5 years he's
released three since Rodeo but he just
has not hit this peak again it's just
too good and that's not to say that he
couldn't do that I think he could if he
really tried this album was just so
dialed into to the sound that he was
creating that it just it's I don't know
I I don't think the word Masterpiece is
too big to use here a lot of people talk
about this as a trap album and I don't
think that's accurate or appropriate
really at all it feels much more like
this grungy Prague album that is created
using trap elements cuz there's so much
on here that doesn't feel like rap at
all I know he says on the album I am
everything except rapper most of it he
is just singing and just kind of guiding
us through these bizarre and enveloping
instrumentals I know when I first heard
this album I was it didn't really click
for me at all I think the only song I
liked was Piss On Your Grave with Kanye
and that was cuz I was a Kanye fan but
my little brother was insistent he told
me this was a great album and I finally
listened to it on a plane and that
changed my life truly that moment
changed my life because I had never
heard anything like this hearing it in
that context I almost felt like catat
and listening to it that was the vibe I
got like this whole world just swirling
around somebody I don't know I don't
know how to explain that it sounds weird
but even if you listened to this album
Have you listened to it with headphones
have you really isolated yourself and
immersed yourself in the music if not
give that a try it might change it a
little for you it definitely worked for
me because it went from an album that I
didn't really like at all to an album I
seriously love and I have found nothing
that scratches the same itch as this
album does for me and I do think Hip-hop
is the appropriate genre to put this in
at least as an umbrella category but
it's so much more than that if there's
anybody watching this that hasn't heard
Rodeo wow you're in for a tree truly to
listen to this album for the first time
well I guess in my case it was the
second but to listen to this album for
the first or second time and have that
experience that I did it's it's truly
mind-blowing so I hope for anybody that
hasn't that you listen to this album and
if you do I would just say give it some
room give it some space give it the
attention it deserves so I know which
ones are my favorites on here and
honestly most of the songs on here are
some of my favorites that Travis Scott's
ever made the big one the big one
probably the best track he's ever put
out uh 90210 towards the back end of the
track it just kind of opens up into this
really cool I don't even know how to
describe it oh man it's much more like a
hip-hop beat in the second half but it's
better than I don't know 90 95% of Beats
I've ever heard it's just it's really
something my second favorite track is
probably the Kanye track that was the
one I liked when I heard it the first
time it is just another massive song
it's just got such an edge to it that it
isn't quite present on the rest of the
album but it's not a bad thing because
that song goes way too hard you don't
need to go that hard on a whole album it
is a very unique album it's a very
singular listening experience and yeah
if anybody hasn't heard it really give
yourself the time to do so because it is
something
special at number 14 we've got a mixtape
my favorite mixtape Chance the Rapper
Acid
[Music]
Rap this pressing is almost certainly a
bootleg I think there might have been an
official pressing at some point I can't
recall but as far as I know these are
just clear kind of a cloudy clear Chance
the Rapper man what a character uh I
feel like feels very unfortunate that so
much discussion around Chance the Rapper
is now focused on his album the big day
which was a bit of a disaster lost in
that conversation is the fact that he
made Acid Rap but maybe it's not that
lost one of the things you see a lot in
that conversation is I can't believe
that we got the big day from the guy who
made Acid Rap this is his best album
it's not even an album It's a mixtape
but it is his best work I stand by that
I'm sure not everybody agrees but come
on it's a really really special project
this album came out in 2013 which was
really the year that I started becoming
a fan of hip-hop so it means a lot to me
in that sense because it was one that I
adopted early on into my journey I think
I bought a CD of it on eBay which you
don't need to do cuz it's a mixtape and
mixtapes are free but I wanted a CD and
I'm sure whoever I paid that for is
roding in prison now chance is a very
gifted rapper and he shows that all
throughout this project the album is
very personal it's very introspective
there are songs that run all kinds of
different emotions he's got an interlude
about love that's fantastic he's got
songs about losing friends to violence
living in Chicago and the difficulties
of summertime and what that means for
people and and then of course he's got
some fun tracks on here with like abou
or Action Bronson where he's just having
a good time you get just about
everything you could want from one
artist on one project chance is one of
those artists that some people have a
hard time with his voice cuz they find
it annoying some people say that about
Danny Brown too another one of my
favorites I don't know I think he leans
into that with some adlibs that are kind
of purposefully annoying or goofy but
you can't deny the man's rapping ability
I mean he's got bars he didn't bring
many bars on the big day sure but he
brought them on Acid Rap I'm pretty sure
this story is that he was doing acid
when he made this album and that's why
he called it that I'm not trying to
endorse or encourage drug use but he
definitely didn't take acid when he made
the big day and it shows this is a
spectacular project it's one that I
return to a lot it's one that I enjoy
from front to back I love the album
cover too it's such a cool blend of
colors an album is complete it's one of
those ones where it's kind of hard to
pick favorites cuz they're just depends
on what mood you're in you know what
song is going to register with you on a
given day my number one has to be acid
rain I've always been a huge fan of that
song I made a point of trying to
memorize that one when I was first
getting into this album I was just super
impressed with the lyricism and the
storytelling on that track it's just
it's really cool truthfully it's hard to
pick favorites elsewhere because there
are so many great songs on here and it
fluctuates but one that I return to a
lot one of my favorites is probably the
outro everything's good and that's the
one that features a voicemail from his
dad man the instrumental is so nice the
instrumentals the production on this
album is fantastic it's a mixtape so I'm
sure a lot of it is samples or other
people's songs there's at least one
sample of a Beat from The Chronic yeah
that that outro is just beautiful man
the piano the keys are so great when he
starts rapping on it it just he brings
such a good energy to that song and to
this whole project it's
infectious number 13 is kind of a genre
departure we're talking about Casey
Musgraves golden
hour I believe this is a clear pressing
so so Casey Musgraves I listened to her
previous album which was pageant
material and I had maybe heard some of
the other tracks that she put out before
that I knew that there was something
about her something about her that kind
of set her apart from a lot of country
artists I'm not a big connoisseur of
country music I think a lot of what I'm
exposed to for Country it's not that
great that's kind of radio stuff though
I know I need to dig deeper if I want to
find the good stuff but Casey Musgraves
is interesting because she is Radio
friendly and she is kind of presented to
you even if you are a surface level
country fan and if you're just comparing
her to a lot of those other surface
level artists she does have something
special I knew that on pageant material
cuz I found myself connecting with these
songs and being kind of impressed with
them I had no idea what was coming with
golden hour so golden hour comes out
this is 2018 and it is just wall to--all
every song on here is great I don't
think there's a single skip there's
nothing that I don't like on here and
she just has some incredible incredible
tracks and I don't think she wrote it
all herself but she's definitely
involved in the songwriting process a
lot of it is personal I did actually
write write a review about this album so
side note here I'm doing this project
where I'm listening to all the albums in
this book called 1,1 albums to listen to
before you die uh hopefully when I
finish it I don't die but I'm about a
little more than halfway through I've
done a lot of them and there are a lot
of great albums on there this one is on
there and so I wrote a review for it and
I know I wrote a review for a bunch of
the albums that appear in my top 10 of
the 2010s too so uh let me know in the
comments if you guys be interested in me
just reading some of those reviews I
might do it for the the next video but
the one thing I want to bring up here
that I know I wrote in that review is I
I use the term glass Cannon for Casey
musk Graves I I see that term a lot in
gaming when you have like a character
that does a lot of damage but can be
destroyed easily I feel like her voice
is sort of a glass Cannon because
there's a delicacy to her voice and the
way that she sings but subject matter
wise it like she just hits all the right
spots for me I mean look at ATT track
like mother I'm not telling you to go
listen to that one in isolation you got
to arrive at that by listen listening to
the album but mother is a song that will
wreck you emotionally if you manage to
make it through that song without at
least tearing up you might need to go to
a doctor that's just the one song and
it's like I don't even know if it's a
minute long this album ended up winning
album of the year at the Grammys we love
the Grammys don't we no we don't but I
think that is the one time in my
lifetime that I've seen album of the
year go to the right album I'm not
holding my breath for the next time it
happens that's for sure but I truly
think she deserved it this really was
the album that I turned to the most from
2018 and there were a lot of great
albums there but golden hour is just
something else man it's so vibrant it's
so emotional it just I I don't know how
to explain it it's not country enough to
be perceived as country I think by
people who don't like country music and
it's not quite pop enough if you're
somebody who's just deterred by pop
music it's possible you'd hate it from
both angles but I feel like it hits a
really great Sweet Spot between those
genres at times on here she reminds me
of sufan Stevens not that she's as good
of a songwriter but I think just the
obser obervational Simplicity of your
music I'm not saying she's on his level
but in terms of the emotion that she's
capable of evoking from me pretty great
stuff we'll see sufian on the next video
that's another spoiler for you so if I
had to pick two favorites here to
recommend I would definitely recommend
the intro Slow Burn that one's a bit
more country but it just gives you a
good sense of what she's capable of and
the lyrics are great and then of course
another great one that I'd have to
recommend is oh what a world that one's
more kaleidoscopic more psychedelic in
nature not too much so it's still kind
of rooted as a pop song but it's a
beautiful sentiment it's a beautiful
song check that one out too but yeah if
you've got the time and haven't heard
the whole thing again I'm going to say
this for all the albums but it's worth
listening
to number 12 we've got school boy Q's
habits and
[Music]
contradictions it should be very obvious
to anyone who's heard this album that
yeah this is a bootleg there's no actual
vinyl pressing of this this is it's kind
of a slightly gold ttin hinged clear
habits and contradictions man this is
another album that came very early in my
journey into hip-hop this one came out
in 2012 I would have come on to it in
2013 I am such a huge fan he's one of my
favorite rappers period And this is
probably still my favorite album he's
made if you don't know the history of
school boy Q he used to be the hyp man
of the group in TDE he made music but it
wasn't all that special something
changed for him and he just decided to
take things more seriously to take rap
more seriously he put out a project
called setbacks before this that was
more of mixtape and that one's really
good but then this one was just
something else I think I found this one
because uh my cousin sent me a link to
the song blessed with Kendrick Lamar
that I was really impressed with I feel
like he does more to get you emotionally
than Kendrick does which is kind of
crazy cuz we all know Kendrick to be
this super gifted Lyricist but school
boy Q really hits to the core when he
wants to there are excellent features
all over this the production is topnotch
a lot of weird beats if I had describe
it I would say that it's it's very
atmospheric it feels like he's very much
exploring his own mind with this project
and the title kind of suggests that that
he's in a process of self-examining but
that doesn't mean that it's not fun to
listen to cuz it really is all over this
album I'm impressed with the fact that
his hooks are often really complex but
they still manage to be catchy and he
does a lot of them himself and it's not
like he's a singer but he just makes
Great Rap hooks a lot of the tracks do
kind of feel of the era I didn't realize
they would until you know now we're more
than 10 years from its release and yeah
a lot of it does feel kind of 2012 but I
still adore this project it's still one
of my favorites not just from him but
from all of TDE boy this is going to be
a hard one to pick favorites on how do I
even do that I think There He Go is
fantastic I think blessed is fantastic
blessed is what got me into it so maybe
it'll get you into it too if you wanted
to start with just one Nightmare on fig
street is really great even the
interlude tuy nose is also just very
cool very dark the production is just so
nice I really do think he is a rapper
that is often forgotten in conversations
he has made some fantastic FC music all
the way up through his last album crash
talk crash talk wasn't as well received
I think most people view it to be his
Worst Album but even on there there's
some of his best work he is just an
incredibly talented rapper that I think
deserves more credit more praise for the
things that he does I'm really hoping he
drops another album this year I've been
hearing that that might be the case
fingers crossed we'll see if you haven't
listened to school boy Q at all and you
don't know where to start you can start
here it's really
[Music]
great finally at number 11 this is the
final album for this video it is from no
worries
[Applause]
yes Anderson Pac Anderson pack however
you want to say it he's an artist that I
have a strong connection to his music
and I'll get into that more when I talk
about Malibu Which is higher up on the
list but the stuff with knowledge no
worries as a Duo it's incredible what
they're doing and they're also supposed
to release an album this year so please
again fingers crossed I need more music
for no no worries no worries is a
collaborative project between
singer/rapper SL drummer Anderson Pac
and Hip-Hop producer knowledge if you're
not familiar with knowledge he's a
really great lowii hip-hop artist I
don't know maybe he would take issue
with the term lowii CU it seems a little
too commercial he's very underground
he's very prolific too he releases tons
of mixtapes a lot of great samples that
I don't know how he clears him he
probably doesn't I truly believe
knowledge is one of the great producers
of our time I think he should be up
there in conversations with guys like
Dilla or or The Alchemist or whoever
else he really is that good so he and
Anderson pck made this song suede which
you might have heard already suede is
the big single that preceded this album
and I think it was swaye that caught the
attention of Dr Dre and after Dr Dre
found his music you know Anderson Pac
had appearances on his Compton album
eventually would sign to his label the
rest is history he's Grammy winning he's
doing projects with Bruno Mars he really
blew up after just a couple years but
this one is very special man he ack
knowledge tapped into to this very
specific sound so knowledge in his
production he uses a lot of soul samples
from like the' 60s and '70s and on this
project specifically Anderson pck he's
kind of inhabiting this role of like a
pimp or a pimp type of character the
music is you know openly and comfortably
misogynistic as you would expect it's
kind of like he's emulating that era of
exploitation films and of course
knowledge's production lends to it
perfectly I mean hand in hand these guys
really really nail the aesthetic they're
going for front to back this is one of
the most Rel listenable albums that I've
ever heard I've listened to this more
times than I could count there's just
not a weak spot and it flows extremely
well everything on here is exceptional
favorites on this one I'm not going to
pick uh suede or link up I know those
are the big singles if you haven't heard
those listen to those of course anyway
cuz they're extraordinary but aside from
those two singles I want to go a little
deeper one of my favorites on here is
what more can I say it's got a great
looping sample great progression from
Anderson P he definitely puts his heart
in into this one and another one that is
also my favorite for similar reasons
because he puts his heart into it
Starlight Starlight is another fantastic
track it feels like sort of the last
song playing on the Dance Floor Last
Song of the night and I've never heard
someone so affectionately called a woman
a [__] it's just a really special
feeling and a really special moment that
that track captures and honestly you
could say that about the whole album
obviously I'm looking forward to the new
album they've put out some great singles
who knows if it's going to be on the
same level as this first project and I'm
not saying that pessimistic I want it to
be and I hope it will be but this one is
just so high in the stratosphere for me
I'd be shocked if they could capture
lightning in a bottle a second time it's
got a lot of tracks but it's a short
album it's definitely one you can listen
to in one sitting and yeah if you
haven't please please do [__] every
single I said I was de so there you have
it there's 20 through 11 that's part two
of this series obviously there's going
to be one more part it might be the
longest because I might have more to say
about those albums but we shall see so
thank thank you guys for tuning in I
hope you enjoyed uh let me know in the
comments if you got any feedback on
these albums if you feel the same way
about any of them or if you feel
differently and yeah let me know if you
guys would be interested in me sort of
reading some of my written reviews as
part of that next video if you are I
might throw those in there for some of
those thanks for tuning in and I'll see
you on the next one